c'est donc le jour de gloire pour l' us
orléans le club de football du loiret
reçoit le paris saint germain ce soir en
8e de finale de la coupe de la ligue
un véritable événement pour la métropole
orléanaise 9000 spectateurs sont
attendus au stade de la source
lucie seco nous attend en direct sur
place bonsoir l'uci comment est
l'ambiance chez les supporters à moins
de deux heures du coup d'envoi
vous l'entendez l'ambiance est à son
comble ici nous sommes devant l'entrée
du des supporters du stade de la source
des supporters très impatient on en a
même rencontré à 18 heures qui essayait
encore d'acheter des places mais
malheureusement c'est archi complet on
l'a bien compris et bien pour les autres
iront au zénith et on a rencontré des
supporters qui étaient là dès 18 heures
impossible de rater l'entrée d'ici il ya
des zones de sécurité qui sont
importantes et bien ils étaient
impatients puisque ils espèrent voir un
exploit on est au psg est bien le grand
favori on l'a bien compris mais on est
un peu raide s'exploite peut-être que
mon 89 on a rencontré des gens qui y
était mais bon bah dumas les trois m'ont
très bien un petit exploit de d'orléans
celles ci portent à voir les ont quand
même quoi et donc on voyait bien que ça
se passe bien pour le prochain tour et
pensez jamais recevoir une autre équipe
karim ziani et pierre bouby on peut que
gagner franchement un pierre bouby
arrière ça passe pas et karim ziani va
il va nous faire un match comme il ya
comme il ya dix ans à l'om et ça va on
va on va les gagner peut-être de 1,3 et
ça va passer quoi
il ya des supporters de tout âge ici des
supporters parisiens des supporters or
les allées peu importe l'important qui
quel que soit le gagnant c'est le show
ces le spectacle c'est du mbac pc du
cavalier en tout cas il l'espère même
s'il n'ya pas neymar ce soir ils sont là
pour voir le grand psg et même si arles
et en perd ça sera le spectacle qui
compte ce soir effectivement merci
beaucoup lui si on va rejoindre alain
eudes à présent qui se trouve à quelques
mètres de vous sur la pelouse du stade
de la source
bonsoir alain vous êtes avec philippe
boutron le président de l'us orléans
leur football
effectivement rebecca alors c'est le
jour de gloire un pour lui assurer on
l'a vu il ya un instant 9000 spectateurs
sont attendus ce soir
et quel que soit le résultat de la
rencontre finalement ce match entrera
dans l'histoire de ce club et des
moments historiques y en a pas eu tant
que ça pour cet us orléans puisque on se
souvient bien sûr de la finale de la
coupe de france perdue contre l'as
monaco c'était en 1980 qu'il ya eu donc
ce fameux huitième de finale de coupe de
france contre le paris saint germain a
gagné c'était à l'époque en 1989 par
match aller retour 4-0 quand même pour
lui et sow sur la pelouse du parc des
princes à l'aller et puis 1 3 à 3 ici au
match retour
alors philippe boutron vous êtes le
président actuel de cet us orléans
loiret football il fallait finalement
une sorte d' affiches de ce genre un
événement comme celui là pour que l' us
orléans retrouve finalement sa place
dans l'histoire du football français
c'est un peu cela absolument en plus sur
leurs il ya une culture kupka très très
forte puisque on voit la mobilisation
est très importante et pour nous c'est
vraiment une super opportunité de
recevoir un club aussi prestigieux que
le paris saint-germain alors il ya des
fonds staff fantasmagorie autour de ce
match on se dit que c'est le jackpot
finalement pour un club comme le vôtre
parce qu'on se dit que vous allez faire
une superbe recettes ce soir qu'il y a
évidemment la petite
prime offerte par par la lfp par
l'organisateur la ligue de football
professionnel et pourtant au bout du
compte j'ai l'impression que ça n'est
pas aussi rose que cela pour une raison
très simple parce qu'on a privilégié la
fidélité c'est à dire qu'on a fait en
sorte de récompenser nos partenaires nos
abonnés et nos bénévoles
on leur a donné priorité pour acquérir
des billets supplémentaires
et puis on est restée très raisonnable
sur le prix des places en fait les notre
objectif c'est de faire en sorte d'une
grande soirée de football et de faire
que orléans devienne une place forte du
foot et puis habituer les gens à venir
au stade et ne pas faire de l'argent
pour de l'argent mais surtout
récompenser les gens qui nous suivent
dans les années les plus pénibles qu'on
a pu connaître par le passé
juste un mot évidemment sur le résultat
de ce soir vous êtes allez on va dire
face à un infime espoir d'être qualifiés
pourtant on s'accroche à cette infime
espoir
je pense qu'une des vertus du football
on l'a vu c'est un privé il ya sortie 3
le tour précédent si je pense que c'est
un des rares sports où tout est possible
et puis peut-être qu'on verra au penalty
comme le penalty nous porte chance
merci beaucoup philippe boutron je vous
souhaite un très bon match à une très
très bonne réussite pour cette soirée
voilà avoue rebecca évidemment ici la
fête va est d'être à son paroxysme dans
un petit peu moins de deux heures et oui
effectivement tout est possible merci
beaucoup alain merci à votre invité on
écoute à présent la réaction de
l'entraîneur de l'us orléans est didier
ollé nicolle de trois questions posées
par mélody stevenson appréhendez vous
cette rencontre
quand on prépare un match sur et que sur
le tableau et on marque cavani di maria
neymar et mbappé thiago silva ac ce cas
wallace et c'est quelque chose de tout à
fait particulier par rapport à nos
habitudes lui et souhaite elle quand
même une chance de gagner
récemment psg a été mis un petit peu en
difficulté à strasbourg à toulouse et je
suis intimement persuadé que sur un
match dans notre bonne période puisque
sur onze matches on a perdu 1 dont il ya
pas d années lumière en arrière il ya un
mois en arrière en prenant très très peu
de buts parce qu'il y avait un vrai
savoir faire un vrai investissement de
tout le monde
on était capables de mettre nos
adversaires en difficulté quelles
stratégies pour déstabiliser le psg
il faut travailler encore plus que
d'habitude puisque ils ont ils ont trop
de qualités techniques trop de qualités
de vitesse de fulgurances à sion si on
n'est pas très très solide très très
compact ce sera très difficile
et puis après aussi la maîtrise la
maîtrise technique
1 parce que si on si on s'exprime pas ce
n'est pas capable de mettre le ballon de
pied sur le ballon et de deux joues et à
deux de proposer des choses et qu'on
leur rend systématiquement le ballon il
y aura trop de vagues qui vont venir et
puis on va on va vite on va vite et
pour ceux qui s'en souviennent du us
orléans qui bat le psg on l'a dit c'est
déjà arrivé par le passé c'était en
avril 1989 lors de la huitième de finale
de la coupe de france 29 ans plus tard
les anciens joueurs de l'usso se sont
réunis lors d'un déjeuner avec l'espoir
d'un nouvel exploit
un mélodies stevenson et philippe roy
maison rencontre et 1989
l' us orléans créé l'exploit face au psg
robbie langueur et ce magnifique
à cette époque les orléanais s'impose et
la ville s'enflamme va neuf ans plus
tard nous avons rencontré les anciens
joueurs
aujourd'hui ils vivent aux quatre coins
de la france mais exceptionnellement
match oblige ils se sont dit oui pour
des retrouvailles et cette fois ci sans
crampons on a tous les mêmes souvenirs
l'arrivée au parc où il a découvert du
parc le match retour à la source
le public était dans la tribune un stade
plein comme un oeuf et une ambiance un
peu particulière dans la fin des mages
on pense il avait dit le résultat paris
saint-germain orléans 4 et les
commentateurs vietnam et vous trompez
c'est 4 à 0 et menace est bien géré au
carton plein donc ça ça me met tout dire
mais c'est vrai qu'on avait fait un
match superbe et l'équipe actuelle de
l'ue sos perd à son tour pourquoi pas
résisté au psg
un psg beaucoup plus grand et combatif
aujourd'hui rien d'effrayant pour
certains tops aux pronostics le match ce
sera ce soir même s'il ya un pour cent
de chances de se qualifier match et je
leur souhaite de faire un bon match et
pourquoi pas l'exploit et pour les
réunir il a fallu beaucoup de patience
et de la logistique mais au final quel
bonheur de se retrouver ça m'a pris
beaucoup de temps ça m'a pris beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup de petits soucis et
effectivement je suis un peu ému parce
que pourquoi la fête c'est ce soir et
puis effectivement tout a une fin
on va se quitter ce soir au bout de 30
ans on verra peut-être pas
[Musique]
vingt neuf ans plus tard ses anciens
joueurs n'auraient manqué pour rien au
monde cette ambiance délirante d'avant
match
[Musique]
et sachez que notre équipe web est aussi
mobilisée sur l'événement ce soir un
live du déroulé du match est à suivre
sur notre site et les réseaux sociaux
facebook twitter et instagram à partir
de 21h